Los negocios no le han salido bien a Candace,
así que tendrá una venta de liquidación
este fin de semana.
Tiene actualmente
1900 pesos en bienes,
que consisten en 250 limpiadores de oídos
y 175 cepillos para la nariz.
Escribe una ecuación para representar
el precio mínimo por un limpiador de oídos,
"E", lo voy a utilizar con esta variable,
con la variable "E"
y por un cepillo de la nariz,
por el precio mínimo de un cepillo de la nariz
que lo voy a poner con la letra "N",
"N" mayúscula,
que Candace debe establecer
para quedar pareja sin pérdidas ni ganancias.
Y bueno,
pues aquí tenemos que poner la ecuación,
ahora, ¿qué datos tenemos?
Nosotros sabemos que Candace
tiene 250 limpiadores de oídos,
por lo tanto voy a poner aquí mis
250 limpiadores de oídos
y a estos los voy a multiplicar por lo que
va a valer cada uno de ellos
y aquí dice que cada uno de
ellos tiene un precio mínimo de "E",
por lo tanto voy a poner 250 que multiplica...
que multiplica a "E", ok,
y a esto tenemos que sumarle,
bueno, pues,
¿cuántos cepillos
para la nariz tiene?
A esto le voy a sumar 175, ok,
que es  la cantidad de cepillos
para la nariz que tiene...
déjame ponerle un poco de espacio aquí...
ok.
Y a esto lo tengo que multiplicar por el precio mínimo
de cada uno de los cepillos para la nariz,
voy a multiplicar esto por "N", ok.
250 por "E"
más 175 por "N",
bueno, pues esa es la cantidad de dinero
que ella tiene invertida en limpiadores de oídos
y también en cepillos para la nariz,
pero  nosotros sabemos que
esta cantidad es de 1900 pesos,
justo eso nos dice el problema,
ella tiene actualmente
1900 pesos en bienes
y por lo tanto esta cantidad,
esto si lo vendiera por completo,
debe de
ser igual...
debe de ser igual que 1900...
que 1900
pensando en el precio mínimo en
que ella lo puede vender
y esto es para que ella no pierda más de
la cantidad que tiene en bienes actualmente.
Si esto fuera menor que 1900,
pues bueno,
entonces ella estaría perdiendo dinero.
Ok, ahora dice,
un gran comerciante
le ofrece a Candace
comprar todo su inventario
a precio de mayoreo,
equivalente a 4 pesos
por limpiador de oídos
y 7 pesos por cepillo de la nariz.
¿Debería Candace aceptar esta oferta
si no quiere tener pérdidas?
Y bueno, para eso, déjame traer aquí mi libreta de apuntes para resolver esta última pregunta
y poder contestarla justo aquí,
entonces déjame sacar
mi libreta de apuntes...
Muy bien y vamos a recordar
que es lo que teníamos hasta ahorita.
Nosotros ya habíamos obtenido la ecuación
que estaba escrita justo aquí,
esa ecuación la habíamos obtenido
fijándonos en la cantidad
de limpiadores de oídos que teníamos que eran 250, ok, los voy a poner aquí,
250 y a esto lo multiplicaba
por el precio mínimo
por un limpiador de oídos,
el precio mínimo era "E", ok,
el precio mínimo no lo sabemos
y si a esto le sumamos,
ok,
la cantidad de cepillos para la nariz
que tenemos que es 175,
ok, a esto le voy a sumar 175
y lo voy a multiplicar por el precio mínimo
que cuesta cada uno de los cepillos para la nariz,
que por cierto es "N"...
entonces déjame
ponerlo con este color...
por "N"...
esto tiene que ser exactamente igual
a la cantidad  de dinero
que tenía Candance en bienes,
que es 1900
y por lo tanto voy a decir que esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 1900,
de tal manera que esta ecuación
representa  el precio mínimo
al cual debe de vender
sus productos Candance.
Y bueno, ahora lo que quiero es ver si le conviene
la oferta que le está ofreciendo este comerciante,
dice, un gran comerciante le ofrece a Candance
comprar todo su inventario a precio de mayoreo,
equivalente a 4 pesos por limpiador de oídos
y 7 pesos por cepillo para la nariz.
¿Debería Candance aceptar esta oferta
si no quiere tener pérdidas?
Bueno,
si ella no quiere tener pérdidas,
entonces lo que le tiene que ofrecer este,
este gran comerciante
debe de ser
mayor o igual que 1900 pesos,
porque si es algo
menor que 1900 pesos,
bueno, pues en definitiva
no le conviene a Candance.
Y para eso, este comerciante
le está ofreciendo 4 pesos...
y déjame ponerlo con este color...
le está ofreciendo 4 pesos
por cada limpiador de oídos,
mientras que por otra parte,
le está ofreciendo 7 pesos
por cada uno de sus cepillos para la nariz,
por lo tanto,
¿qué te parece si en esta ecuación,
sustituimos el precio mínimo
por un limpiador de oídos?
es decir "E" por 4, ok,
y voy a sustituir 7 pesos
por el precio mínimo para cada cepillo de la nariz.
Ok, y entonces esto quiero que sea
mayor o igual que 1900,
es decir,
me va a quedar lo siguiente,
250 que multiplica a "E",
pero vamos a ver
si cumple que al menos,
es el precio mínimo,
estos 4 pesos,
por lo tanto voy a multiplicarlo por 4, ok,
y a esto le voy a sumar...
a esto le voy a sumar 175...
175, ok,
que va a multiplicar a "N",
pero "N" es el precio mínimo
de cada uno de los cepillos de la nariz
y este comerciante
le está ofreciendo 7 pesos,
por lo tanto, vamos a multiplicarlo por 7, ok,
esto tiene que ser
más grande o igual,
tiene que ser
mayor o igual que 1900,
si esto no es más grande o igual
que 1900,
entonces sí
vamos a aceptar su oferta.
Y bueno, para realizar esta operación que tengo aquí,
vamos a traer a mi calculadora,
ok, y mi calculadora me dice que,
¿cuánto es 250
si lo multiplicamos por 4 pesos?
ok,
y a esto le sumamos, 175
que  lo vamos a multiplicar por 7,
ok, y esto va a ser
igual a 2225, de lujo,
vamos a escribirlo aquí,
esto es 2000...
y déjame ponerlo con otro color,
lo voy a poner con este color de aquí...
2225,
lo cual en definitiva
si es mayor o igual que 1900
y por lo tanto, nos ponemos bastante contentos
porque si nos conviene,
o bueno, a Candance le conviene
aceptar la oferta de este gran comerciante.
Por lo tanto,
vamos a poner aquí mi respuesta...
déjame traer aquí la página...
y vamos a decir
que sí vamos a aceptar la propuesta.
Y comprobamos nuestra respuesta,
perfecto, estamos bien.